on t'a priem pas une prime justement
avant l'heure c'est pas l'heure
après la
c'est trop d'à
sait-on ce qui se cache derrière cette
petite phrase que nous prononçons de
nombreuses fois dans une journée
quelle heure est il vous serez peut-être
étonné d'apprendre que leur cela se
fabriquent leur se fabrique ici à
l'observatoire de paris au bureau
international de l'air comme elle se
fabrique dans les observatoires des
capitales de tous les pays du monde mais
ça se fabrique survie d'une façon assez
compliqué parce que on a besoin pour les
recherches scientifiques d'une ère
extrêmement précise et en fait c'est
compliqué parce qu'il n'y a pas qu'une
seule heure on a besoin de plusieurs
échelles de temps au travail
scientifique et principalement des temps
donné par l'astronomie par son ami qu'on
appelle aussi le temps universel et
d'autre part du temps donné par les
étalons atomique de temps il domine
quelle différence y at-il entre
collègues dans l'astronomie qui tend à
tomic et le temps astronomique est donné
par la rotation de la terre et on
observe avec des instruments
astronomiques alors atomique n'est pas
l'heure d'une horloge en particulier c
est une heure qui est calculé comme une
moyenne les indications de toutes les
horloges que l'on a à la surface de la
terre
par conséquent c'est n'est pas une
horloge qui à un moment donné donne
réellement le temps atomique
c'est un produit de calcul est le
produit de ce calcul ce sont des
corrections
il faut apporter aux heures qui sont lus
sur les horloges de chaque laboratoire
ces corrections seront distribués après
coup environ un mois après vous pourrez
dire que vous calculer l'heure exacte un
mois après que
oui mais bien entendu pour les besoins
immédiats ou peut néanmoins se fier à
son horloge pour avoir leur atomique une
sorte d' extrapolations de leurs atonie
avec une exactitude qui est excellente
quand même quand ces landes c'est le
millième de seconde pourquoi avoir créé
leur atomique le reste conomique ne
suffisait pas je reste aux knicks ne
suffit pas parce qu'elle n'est pas très
régulières et des étalons atomique de
fréquences le temps donne une heure qui
est beaucoup plus uniforme et qui de
plus peut se lire avec une précision
bien meilleur on ne peut obtenir que le
millième de seconde comme précision sur
leur astronomiques alors que l'on peut
aisément obtenir le millionième et même
le milliardième de seconde sur les
étalons établir si je comprends bien le
reste renault mais qui est irrégulier à
dire qu'il y ait des milliers d heures
de plus d'une heure ou deux heures de
moins d'une heure après les légèrement
irrégulière naturellement ce n'est pas
sensible pour le grand public mais c'est
sensible que la recherche scientifique
et leur leurs atomes et qu'elle leur
auto milk et du vraiment très grande
régularité gens nous donnent souvent un
exemple si l'on place côte à côte deux
étalons atomique de temps et bien une
divergeront d'une seconde au bout de dix
mille ans
dans la vie courante on doit garder le
temps astronomiques mais vous êtes tout
à l'heure que certains astronomiques et
est irrégulier si l'on comparé au temps
atomique et finalement il s'en écarte
alors si l'on vivait sur le temps
atomique et bien on finirait par voir
une heure qui n'auraient pas de
relations avec le mouvement du soleil ça
c'est dire qu'en fait c'est leur
astronomique qui s'écarte de votre
bateau ni lui fx c'est cela oui et la
vitesse à laquelle ces deux heures ces
cartes assez faible elle est d'ordre
d'une seconde par an actuellement
mais néanmoins cette différence de
quelques secondes au bout de quelques
années est gênante pour certaines
applications et notamment pour la
navigation maritime
il ya une autre ère encore seller
sidéral qu'est ce que c'est clair si des
rages roller fédéral c'est une variante
du temps astronomiques
une variante du temps universel qui est
utilisé dans les observatoires et qui du
reste ne sort guère leur sidéral est
utilisé par les astronomes parce que une
même étoile passe au méridien à chaque
jour à la même heure sidéral
si bien que il est commode pour les
astronomes qui ont des excavations
particulière à faire d'avoir par exemple
réveil matin à régler en heure c'est
viral
est-ce que leur que j'ai sur ma montre
et l'ère atomique ou leur astronomiques
c'est une sorte de beurre de compromis
une troisième c'est une troisième heure
qu'on appelle le temps universel
coordonné qui est très proche du temps
astronomiques mais qui est obtenu à
partir du temps atomique en dans le vent
ou en ajoutant un nombre entier de
seconde plus bien entendu le nombre
entier d'ernst pas du système les
fuseaux horaires comme eh bien si ça
c'est ce que j'allais vous dire leur que
j'ai sur ma montre n'est pas la même que
celle que celle de new york
donc les heures que l'on à leur atomique
ou leur astrologique en france est
différente de celle de des etats-unis ou
du rss leur atomique que l'on utilise
pour les besoins scientifiques est la
même partout sur toute la surface de la
terre à une fraction de millionième de
seconde près mais recommande comment ça
se passe vous avez des vérifications
entre l'air outre votre heure et celles
d'autres bureaux de leurs les eaux
rouges seront constamment comparé par
des méthodes diverses par des méthodes
radioélectriques et aussi par une
méthode qui est très ancien mais très
simple mais qui reste malgré tout l'une
des plus précises qui consiste à
transporter des horloges en marche
le dernier exemple que je peux vous
donner c'est celui de la mission de colo
il était nécessaire de vérifier que les
aurois j'étais bien synchrone avant la
mission et
les américains se sont promenés travers
le monde avec des orvets sa famille est
en marche pour faire cette vérification
dans votre au mieux on est en national
de leurs ici vous avez l'état l'appareil
autour de nous disons assez compliqué à
quoi sert-il ces appareils sert
précisément à comparer les horloges
d'entre elles les transports d'horloge
dans vous parle ne peuvent pas se faire
d'une façon continue
bien entendu et entre les transports
d'horloge il faut quand même s'assurer
que les horloges conserve bien leur
manche relative n'est ce pas est le seul
aspect avec des moyens électroniques et
nous avons ici un certain nombre de
récepteurs de signaux horaires assez
particulier que l'on utilise pour
vérifier les orages au niveau du
millionième de millionième de seconde
l'horloge parlante que tout le monde
connaît bien qui décrit son téléphone
pour avoir l'air seller atomique seller
sidéral c'est le reste rono me coûter
leur s l'horloge parlante donne cette
heure de compromis dont je vous ai parlé
c'est à dire que l est elle donne à peu
près le temps astronomiques en réalité
pour être tout à fait précis donne le
temps atomique
actuellement c'est le teint atomique -
10 secondes plus une heure mais à partir
du 1er juillet elle donnera le temps
atomique - 11 secondes
plus qu'une aire à cause de ces secondes
de rattrapage que j'ai signalé
alors en fait l'horloge parlante est en
fait une horloge mécanique très
ordinaire
l'horloge parlante telle qu'on la voit
et une machine parlante qui énonce
l'heure mais les quatre au top que l'on
entend sont ceux qui sont donnés par les
horloges atomiques de l'observatoire
c'est à dire la machine parlant elle n'a
pas besoin d'être extrêmement bien
réglée laisse simplement passer les tops
qui eux sont très précis pour quatrième
temps il pourra éventuellement
ces fonds tarde
la la la
ouah
ap
là
ça autrement dit finalement l'air n'est
pas du tout une chose très simple aux
cétacés
c'est même très compliqué
il
mais bon
la terre
- 2 sept
qui
nous ne
votre rigueur que tout le temps perdu